Máxima tensión.
Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os hemos contado
como las relaciones entre Washington y Riad
no pasan por su mejor momento.
De hecho llevan años de capa caída y las
cosas cada vez están peor.
La vieja alianza, la antigua sociedad, la
relación especial entre Riad y Washington
comienza a ser ya cosa del pasado.
¿Y sabéis qué?
En cierta forma este gráfico explica perfectamente
el motivo.
Os lo hemos hablado de ello un montón de
veces: durante años Washington garantizó
la seguridad de la Casa Saud, la casa real
saudi a cambio de que esté país regará
el mercado mundial con un suministro abundante
de petróleo y a Wall Street con los propios
petrodólares que generaba el negocio.
Fue algo así como un matrimonio de pura conveniencia.
(Ningún tratado o pacto de defensa mutua
une o ha unido nunca a Estados Unidos con
Arabia Saudi, pero pese a ello todo el mundo
estaba completamente convencido de que si
la Casa Saud hubiera tenido algún problema,
Estados Unidos hubiera acudido raudo en su
ayuda.
Incluso aunque eso hubiera supuesto emplear
todo su músculo militar.
Y todo eso por no hablar de los miles de “consultores”
militares norteamericanos que entrenaban y
en la práctica apoyaban al ejército saudí.)
Sin embargo, la revolución del fracking lo
cambió absolutamente todo.
De repente Estados Unidos se volvió casi
autosuficiente en cuanto a consumo de petróleo
y entonces comenzó a ver Oriente Medio con
otros ojos….
Y entonces llegó el divorcio.
Pero….
Un momento, porque esta historia ya os la
hemos contado en un pasado vídeo que os dejo
en la descripción.
Así que entonces la pregunta es ¿Por qué
estamos otra vez hablando de Arabia Saudi
y Estados Unidos aquí en VisualPolitik?
Pues…
Básicamente porque el día 5 de octubre los
reyes del petróleo árabe hicieron oídos
sordos a las reiteradas peticiones de la Casa
Blanca y anunciaron todo un bombazo energético
y también político:
("La OPEP+ acuerda el mayor recorte de la
producción de petróleo desde el inicio de
la pandemia".
Es probable que el movimiento para reducir
la producción diaria en 2 millones de barriles
incremente los precios y ayude a Moscú.
WSJ)
Y aquí tenemos que destacar varias claves.
Por un lado, la crisis energética y el freno
al comercio de gas y petróleo con Rusia ha
hecho que el Golfo Pérsico vuelva a convertirse
en un proveedor indispensable para Occidente.
Por ejemplo, las importaciones de gas y petróleo
desde el Golfo han pasado en menos de un año
desde el entorno del 10% a más del 20.
Y eso les da un enorme poder de mercado.
Las petromonarquías lo saben y ahora quieren
sacar tajada.
C1(En este momento todo el mundo necesita
petróleo del Golfo, todo el mundo necesita
a Arabia Saudita y a los Emiratos Árabes
Unidos.
Algunos en Washington definitivamente no se
dan cuenta de que hay un nuevo Golfo y que
ya no aceptamos órdenes de Washington" Abdulkhaleq
Abdulla, profesor de política emiratí.)
Y es que, amigos, amigas, no os penséis que
hablamos de poca cosa.
El dinero está entrando a espuertas en el
Golfo Pérsico.
Hablamos de decenas y decenas, cientos de
miles de millones de dólares extra.
En concreto, el FMI habla de unos ingresos
extra para los exportadores de Oriente Medio
y Asia Central de 320 mil millones de dólares
tan solo en 2022.
Y si en otras ocasiones los jeques apostaron
por contener las subidas del precio del crudo
para castigar a los productores de fracking,
ahora las cosas parecen completamente diferentes.
Digamos que los jeques quieren ante todo rellenar
las arcas reales lo más rápido que les sea
posible.
Y ese es exactamente el motivo que esgriman
para querer mantener el precio del barril
de brent por encima de los 100 dólares.
Ahora bien esta no es la única consecuencia
geoeconómica y política.
La otra tiene que ver directamente con Moscú.
Porque, amigos, la medida aprobada por la
conocida como OPEP+ de recortar la producción
de crudo mundial en 2 millones de barriles
supone todo un espaldarazo para el Kremlin
justo cuándo Occidente está a las puertas
de aprobar su tope de precio al petróleo
ruso.
Y, como veremos, eso no ha pasado desapercibido
absolutamente por nadie.
La pregunta es, ¿están los jeques rescatando
a Rusia?
¡Atentos!
[Pero antes dadme un solo instante porque…
Tenemos que hablar de Internet.
Internet está lleno de hackers, cookies que
no queremos tener y cada vez más restricciones
¿Queréis ver páginas web de cualqu
ier país sin ningún tipo de bloqueo?
¿Queréis navegar por Internet con seguridad?
Pues… no lo penséis más: usad una VPN
como Surfshark VPN.
Surfshark VPN.
Creedme, el tema de la ciberseguridad se lo
toman en serio.
Por ejemplo, Surfshark tiene una herramienta
que se llama CLEANWEB que bloquea todos los
popups de propaganda, por donde se cuelan
más bots y cookies que no queremos tener.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, con una misma
cuenta de Surfshark podrás registrar todos
los dispositivos que quieras ¿Quieres navegar
con seguridad desde tu SmartTV?
¿Desde tu móvil?
¿Desde tu ordenador?
Puedes hacer todo esto con la misma cuenta
de Surfshark.
Y, por supuesto, tenemos una oferta especial
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Si utilizáis el código POLITIK podréis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento más 3 meses
extra totalmente gratuitos.
Tenéis el link en la descripción.
No esperéis más.
Que muchas veces dejamos pasar estas cosas
y, cuando nos queremos dar cuenta, ya es demasiado
tarde.
Entrad en la web y descargaros ya la aplicación.
Y ahora sí, adentremonos en las turbulentas
intrigas políticas de Oriente Medio.]
T1(TORMENTA EN WASHINGTON)
En Washington y, particularmente, en la Casa
Blanca lo tienen muy claro: los saudíes fueron
los grandes culpables de que la OPEP decidiera
recortar su producción de petróleo.
Y que lo hicieran justo a las puertas de las
elecciones de mitad de mandato en Estados
Unidos y justo cuándo peor lo estaba pasando
el régimen de Putin en la Guerra de Ucrania
es algo que consideran casi como un chantaje.
Lo que por otra parte no ha sorprendido a
casi nadie.
Y es que veréis, durante la campaña electoral
Joe Biden dijo que Arabia Saudita era un país
paria y que como tal lo trataría desde el
Despacho Oval.
Esta fue la respuesta del actual presidente
al brutal asesinato del periodista Jamal Khashoggi.
Sin embargo, la invasión rusa de Ucrania
le hizo hacer de tripas corazón.
De repente Occidente necesitaba encontrar
alternativas para poder castigar al Kremlin
cortando las compras de petróleo.
Pero eso no resulta tan sencillo, tras años
de poca inversión en la industria, el mercado
del petróleo del gas estaba terriblemente
tensionado.
Así que al presidente de Estados Unidos y
a otros muchos mandatarios internacionales
tuvieron que ponerse en marcha para encontrar
fuentes alternativas.
Incluso, por el camino, Washington estuvo
dispuesto a tender la mano a países como
Irán o Venezuela.
Con pobres resultados hasta la fecha, todo
sea dicho.
(El caso es que de esta forma los grandes
productores del golfo volvieron a convertirse
en los actores clave de toda esta novela político-energética.
Y por eso a mediados del mes de julio, el
propio Joe Biden visitó a Mohamed Bin Salman
en Arabia Saudi.
No fue el encuentro más amistoso y caluroso
del mundo, pero como gesto marcaba un punto
de inflexión.
La Casa Blanca estaba dispuesto a reiniciar
sus relaciones con Riad, si este país se
unía activamente a la gran coalición internacional
contra Rusia o si al menos tomaba medidas
para enfriar los precios del petróleo y con
ello parte de las presiones inflacionarias
que tan durantemente está castigando a medio
mundo.)
Sin embargo, 2 meses y medio después de la
visita se confirmó lo que casi todo el mundo
ya sospechaba: que el viaje fue un rotundo
fracaso.
Así que lejos de anunciar un incremento en
la producción, la OPEP+, liderada por Arabia
Saudita y la propia Rusia, lo que ha anunciado
es todo lo contrario.
Y eso, podéis creerme, ha desatado la ira
en Washington.
Sobre todo, cuando además, tan solo 5 días
antes de anunciarse la medida, enviados de
la Casa Blanca viajaron hasta Riad para pedirle
al gobierno de Mohammed Bin Salman que no
lo hiciera.
Pero ni con esas.
Y la pregunta es: exactamente, ¿por qué
demonios han tomado esta decisión las petromonarquías
del Golfo?
Pues bien, esta pregunta la responderán muy
pronto en Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de
información financiera de Mutuactivos con
el que participamos.
Si aún no lo conocéis, echadle un vistazo
porque tienen vídeos muy interesantes.
Sea como sea, las reacciones no se hicieron
esperar.
(Varios senadores, incluido Robert Menéndez,
el presidente del poderoso Comité de Relaciones
Exteriores del Senado han pedido ya que se
congele cualquier cooperación con Arabia
Saudi, incluida la que se dé en el campo
militar.
Asimismo, varios senadores y congresistas,
tanto demócratas como republicanos, han anunciado
ya su firme decisión de impulsar una nueva
legislación que suspenda las ventas de armas
al país árabe.
E, incluso, ahora está sobre la mesa la posibilidad
de que tanto la Casa Blanca, como el propio
Congreso, reactiven el conocido como proyecto
de Ley NOPEC, un proyecto de ley con el que
se busca perseguir, sancionar y exigir responsabilidades
a las compañías petroleras que sean propiedad
de gobiernos que formen parte de un cartel
del petróleo.
Este sería sin ir más lejos el caso de Aramco,
la poderosa petrolera saudí.)
La propia Casa Blanca parece ahora dispuesta
no sólo a cambiar su política exterior en
relación al Golfo, sino también su propia
política energética para Estados Unidos.
Si hasta ahora la Administración Biden ha
priorizado la transición energética, eso
podría estar cambiando por completo.
El fracking vuelve a estar de moda.
C2("Vamos a trabajar con nuestros aliados
estadounidenses para aumentar la producción
y asegurarnos de que tenemos la capacidad
de refinación suficiente" Amos Hochstein,
Asesor de Energía de Joe Biden.)
Sea como sea, si algo está claro meridiano
es que la decisión de la OPEP+ supondrá
más dolor para las economías occidentales
y, especialmente, para la vieja Europa.
Con todo, esto no es lo peor.
Lo más preocupante es que el recorte de la
producción justo cuándo peor lo está pasando
Rusia en la Guerra de Ucrania y a las puertas
del invierno, parece ser un claro rescate
para el régimen de Vladimir Putin y una medida
de presión contra Occidente.
Y eso, eso amigos si que resulta mucho peor.
C3("Lo que Arabia Saudi hizo para ayudar a
Putin a continuar librar su despreciable y
viciosa guerra contra Ucrania será recordado
durante mucho tiempo por los estadounidenses".
Chuck Schumer, político demócrata y líder
de la mayoría en el Senado)
C4("No vemos ninguna razón por la que las
tropas y los contratistas estadounidenses
deban seguir proporcionando este servicio
a los países que están trabajando activamente
en contra de nosotros.
Si Arabia Saudita y los Emiratos Árabes Unidos
quieren ayudar a Putin, deberían encomendarse
a él para su defensa" Comunicado de los congresistas
Tom Malinowski, Sean Casten y Susan Wild)
Y la pregunta es, ¿Está la OPEP realmente
apoyando a Rusia?
Atentos.
T2(EL ABRAZO DEL OSO)
En Viena, en la reunión de la OPEP+ que decidió
el recorte de producción hubo dos grandes
protagonistas.
El Ministro de energía saudí Abdulaziz bin
Salman y el Viceprimer Ministro de Vladimir
Putin, Alexander Novak, que días antes había
sido sancionado por Estados Unidos.
C5("La presencia del viceprimer ministro ruso,
sometido a las sanciones de EE.UU., para discutir
el endurecimiento del suministro de petróleo
de cara a un invierno en el que Rusia ya ha
dinamitado sus exportaciones de gas a Europa,
envía un claro mensaje", Roger Diwan, analista
de S&P Global Commodity Insight)
Seamos claros, las petromonarquías insisten
en que el recorte de la producción no es
una cuestión política, sino que solo se
trata de negocios.
Sin embargo, una cosa está clara: los estados
golfo no han condenado la invasión rusa de
Ucrania y no han secundado ninguna de las
sanciones y, ahora, tampoco han escuchado
de su antiguo aliado norteamericano.
Y aquí hay una cuestión muy importante que
tenemos que tener en cuenta: el país con
mucha diferencia más beneficiado por los
recortes en la producción es precisamente
la Rusia de Putin.
¿Por qué?
Pues ahora lo vais a entender perfectamente.
A diferencia de Arabia Saudi, Emiratos, Irak
o Kuwait, los costes de extracción del petróleo
ruso son mucho más altos.
De hecho se estima que de media son el doble
que los de Arabia Saudi.
Hablamos de más de 40 dólares cada barril.
Y eso no es todo.
Las sanciones internacionales y la falta de
compradores han hecho que Rusia esté vendiendo
su petróleo a países como India y China
con descuento de hasta 35 dólares sobre el
precio de cotización global.
Además, como podéis ver en pantalla, redirigir
las ventas rusas de petróleo a mercados tan
lejanos de las fuentes de producción como
China o India implica también plazos mucho
más largos y, por tanto, mayores costes logísticos.
Es decir, 40 dólares de costes de extracción,
35 dólares de descuento comercial y mayores
costes logísticos, suponen que por debajo
de los 80 dólares Rusia deja prácticamente
de ganar dinero con sus exportaciones de crudo.
Y, ¿Sabéis a qué precio estaba el barril
de brent justo antes del anuncio del recorte
de la producción?
Exacto, estaba tocando la barrera de los 80
dólares.
La fuerte desaceleración económica de China
y en general la peor marcha de las economías
occidentales hizo que el precio del petróleo
cayerá cerca de un 20%, pasando de los 100
dólares en el mes de julio a los 80 a finales
de septiembre.
Y eso suponía un terrible castigo precisamente
para Rusia.
Sin embargo, con el recorte de la producción
todo cambia.
Sí, Arabia Saudí ingresará más dinero
por barril, pero también extraerá y venderá
menos barriles.
La diferencia será positiva pero no tan grande.
En cambio para Rusia el incremento en los
precios del petróleo supone una diferencia
abismal.
Por debajo de 80 dólares el barril el Kremlin
prácticamente no gana nada.
Y no olvidemos que en 2021 los beneficios
del petróleo sufragaron el 45% de todo el
gasto público de Rusia.
Es decir, para meterle el dedo en el ojo a
Washington, para reforzar la unidad y la posición
de la OPEP+ como el cartel que fija el precio
internacional del crudo, y para beneficiarse
de la guerra, esta vez las petromonarquías
del golfo han decidido, al menos por ahora,
alinearse con Moscú.
Y es que, no se trata sólo de Arabia Saudi.
Emiratos, por ejemplo, también ha secundado
alegremente el recorte de producción.
Quizás tenga algo que ver que Dubái se haya
convertido en la nueva Meca, en el nuevo refugio
de moda para los oligarcas rusos.
N2(21 de septiembre de 2022: Los rusos huyen
a Dubái, los precios de los billetes se disparan
a 5.000 dólares a medida que aumentan las
tensiones por la amenaza nuclear.
Arabianbusiness)
Desde que diera comienzo la guerra de Ucrania,
los rusos, y particularmente los millonarios
rusos, se han abalanzado sobre Dubái para
comprar propiedades, poner a establecer sus
negocios y poner a salvo sus fortunas.
Por ejemplo, en los Emiratos, comprar una
propiedad de 750.000 dirhams, unos 204 mil
dólares al cambio, te asegura tres años
de residencia.
Y por supuesto las inversiones más grandes
te pueden asegurar mucho más tiempo.
Y aunque las cosas ya no resultan tan fáciles
como antes para los rusos, sobre todo en lo
que respecta a las operaciones financieras,
lo cierto es que se las están ingeniando
para utilizar Dubaí como una de sus nuevas
bases de operaciones.
Lo que por supuesto está contribuyendo a
que esta ciudad esté viviendo una nueva época
dorada.
Ya sabéis, los negocios son los negocios.
Ahora bien, la jugada podría no salirles
tan bien.
T3(LA PARTIDA)
Uno de los grandes errores que suelen cometer
los dictadores y autócratas es sobreestimar
siempre sus cartas.
Como suelen estar rodeados de aduladores y
vivir en especie de burbuja dónde su palabra
es la ley, no pocas veces terminan arriesgando
más de la cuenta.
Esto es exactamente lo que les pasó a dictadores
como Sadam Hussein, Muammar Gaddafi o, más
recientemente, al propio Vladimir Putin con
la invasión de Ucrania.
Ahora podría pasarle algo muy parecido al
líder saudí Mohammed Bin Salman.
Está última jugada deja muy claro que Arabia
Saudi ya no es de ninguna forma un socio confiable
para Occidente.
(Es casi seguro que la producción petrolera
de Estados Unidos y del resto del mundo crecerá
con fuerza durante los próximos años, al
tiempo que también se acelerará el desarrollo
de energías alternativas, incluida la nuclear.
Es decir, la medida de Riad puede terminar
reduciendo los beneficios futuros del país.
Al mismo tiempo la cooperación militar con
Estados Unidos resulta fundamental para el
reino, no solo para poder acceder a los equipos
más modernos y defenderse llegado el caso
de un país como Irán, sino también para
mantener los miles de puestos de trabajo que
se han creado en el país.)
Y desde luego si algo ha dejado claro la guerra
de Ucrania es que si hablamos de equipos avanzados
no hay alternativa a los suministros occidentales
y sobre todo a los norteamericanos.
Y además y sobre todo, Arabia Saudi lleva
años diciendonos que va a invertir gigantescas
cantidades de dinero para diversificar su
economía.
Sin embargo, para que eso ocurra de verdad
necesita si o si cooperar comercialmente con
los países más ricos del mundo.
Es decir, con las empresas de Occidente.
Y medidas como esta no contribuyen lo más
mínimo a ese objetivo.
En cualquier caso, lo que queda claro es que
las petromonarquías han retado al gigante
nortemericano.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué creéis que haran los
Estados Unidos?
¿Podrán los países occidentales evitar
volver a caer bajo la influencia de los países
árabes?
¿Creés que esta medida es puramente comercial
como afirman los saudites o, por contra, estamos
ante un movimiento político?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus impresiones y
abramos debate.
Y por supuesto si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.